you've served in the military for 26
years you've served in combat yeah why
now it's not just as a commander that I
speak but it's as a survivor that I I
just felt I
I needed to I needed to talk about it
but it isn't about me I wanted to give
the perspective of why I am advocating
so strongly for a women in the military
and why I'm advocating that the command
chain has to step up and do their job to
rid us of sexual assault was it
difficult for you to say it publicly in
a forum like that yeah you know it was
it brings back the very real memories
and the realities of it all but I'm glad
I did do you think the prevalence of
sexual assault and abuse in the military
is a national security threat I do I do
for sure I don't want people to think
like well maybe it's just all these
problems we have now that our women in
the military think about it if you have
a predator if you have a rapist who's
serving in uniform you don't deal with
it by keeping a woman out of their unit
because that predator is going to go
assault someone else